we get tattoos to remember where we came  from what to live by we'd loved we get  them because we love and so we don't  forget to be good to each other because  sometimes we need to remind her people  can be mean to us you're gonna want to  scare him sometimes  people will look at you all made up  expect you to be a certain way show them  something they didn't expect life is  full of pain most of it we didn't ask  for it just happen to us so when we  choose to feel pain there's a very good  reason for it  whether we've been planning our tattoos  for five years or five seconds  tasteful noble beautiful whether the  tattoo tells the story of a lifetime  we're just one crazy night we took  control we paid the money we stepped up  to that counter and said I want this on  me forever  we made the choice  what will your choice be